yeah hey Glen I just wanted to say that
what you did back there was awesome
thank you don't worry you won't even
notice Cheyenne is gone oh I'm not
worried it's not my problem anymore what
do you what are you talking about yeah
they they let me go
what yeah they can't just fire you
you've given your whole life to this
place don't worry I'll still be in the
store all the time just as a customer
I'll say stuff like hey yeah can you
tell me where the dental floss says well
probably not because I already know
where it is unless you decide to move it
what what do you what are you talking
about they asked me if I wanted to make
a suggestion for my replacement and
nobody knows this store better than you
no I'm not doing it then they'll just
get someone else
I don't care Glen I'm not taking your
job Amy wait someone is going to be in
that chair tomorrow and that person has
to take care of everyone in this store
I'd rather that person be you than some
stranger Amy you're a leader and the
people here need a leader can you do
that yeah I can do it
Jonah huh you think I'm doing it wrong
but if we stack them five wide and low
they're less prone to toppling what's
wrong
they fired Glenn what yeah so about that
walkout Matteo click that fired while
walking out are you coming yeah
sorry Vasili a teal and green story
Geron all the employees are leaving
early because they're staging over walk
out because Glen got fired
[Music]
you still have my credit card hello
I understand that you're presenting
about Glens I know and I get that
tears oh glands
treat yourself to a plan new cop just
his once jobs going great what could
possibly go wrong
[Music]
it's gonna work I don't know it's worth
a shot right so what now
[Music]
flips it up I have something I'd like to
say I know you're scared this is a big
moment but rest assured cloud 9
it'll be fine without you anyway I've
demagnetized your key cards and you will
receive your final paychecks in the mail
with the cost of your best adapted from
them nothing personal
I wish you all luck but I've got a store
to manage thank you
it's hardly cheered me up
Oh and has a heavenly day
[Music]
you